>> Laura: LEAKS FROM THE
UPCOMING TELL-ALL BOOK FROM JIM
COMEY SEEM MORE TABLOID THAN
TELLING.
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR REPORTEDLY
REVEALED SUCH NUGGETS AS
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S HANDS ARE
SMALLER THAN HIS.
TRUMP'S TIES ARE TOO LONG.
LOOKS LIKE HE'S USING GOGGLES.
FOR GOOD MEASURE, COMEY CALLED
TRUMP ON ETHICAL AND A LIAR.
DEMOCRATS MAY SWOON OVER THE
BOOK, JUST AS THEY CHEERED
COMEY'S ROLE IN THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION BUT ARE STILL
LIVID.
COMEY SAT REOPENING OF THE
HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION LATE IN THE
CAMPAIGN.
BELIEVING IT COULD'VE COST THE
ELECTION.
OUR NEXT GUEST HAS CHOICE
THOUGHTS.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY ARI FLEISCHER.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
THIS BOOK, USUALLY YOU PUT OUT
YOUR HOT STUFF TO GET PEOPLE TO
BUY IT.
IF THIS IS ALL THEY HAVE.
I THINK IT'S A BIG SNORE.
I DON'T SEE WHY THIS BOOK IS
GOING TO SELL COPIES.
LET'S START WITH THE PERSONAL
STUFF.
SEEMS PETTY.
>> HE CALLED HIM A CONGENITAL
LIAR, ACTUALLY, AND AN UNETHICAL
MAN.
MY POINT HERE IS IF THAT'S WHAT
THE FBI THOUGHT OF THE COMMANDER
IN CHIEF, THE PRESIDENT TO WHOM
HE DOES REPORT EVEN THOUGH HE IS
TENURED AND INDEPENDENTLY
APPOINTMENT
APPOINTED, THE HONORABLE
THING WOULD HAVE BEEN FOR HIM TO
RESIGN.
HOW CAN YOU WORK FOR SOMEBODY HE
CONSIDERS UNETHICAL?
HE DOES WORK FOR THE PRESIDENT.
HE'S THE FBI DIRECTOR, ONE OF
THE MORE POWERFUL POSITIONS IN
GOVERNMENT THAT ANSWERS TO THE
PRESENT.
THE HONORABLE THING, IF THAT'S
WHAT HE THOUGHT, WOULD BE TO
RESIGN.
THE JAMES COMEY I KNOW HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A GRAND STANDARD.
IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN IN THIS BOOK
SHOWS THAT EVEN MORE.
>> Laura: AN INTERESTING TWEET
BY FORMER FBI AGENT.
"JAMES COMEY BOOK SECTION 2.4 OF
FBI'S MANUAL COVERS PROHIBITED
DISCLOSURES.
FBI EMPLOYEE SHALL NOT DISCUSS
INFORMATION THAT RELATES TO THE
SUBSTANTIVE MERITS OF ANY
ONGOING OR OPEN INVESTIGATION OR
CASE."
THE IMPLICATION BEING HE
SHOULDN'T BE TALKING ABOUT THIS
INVESTIGATION OR ANYTHING CLOSE
TO IT.
>> I HAVE MORE REASON, THEN YOU
ARE I OR ANYONE WATCHING, TO
DISPARAGE JIM COMEY.
HE IN NO WAY HELPED
HILLARY CLINTON.
DONALD TRUMP, I CAN MAKE THE
ARGUMENT, WOULDN'T BE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE THAN WITHOUT HIM.
I THINK DONALD TRUMP WOULD BE IN
TRUMP TOWER.
TOWERING INFERNO.
>> Laura: COME ON.
THAT'S BAD.
LIBERALS ARE REALLY SALIVATING
THE FACT THAT SOMEONE IN
TRUMP TOWER?
I GET CRITICIZED.
NO REPERCUSSIONS FOR THOSE
COMMENTS.
I WANT TO SEE PAUL BEGALA.
HE SAID MR. COMEY NEEDS TO PUT
HIS BIG BOY PANTS ON, ADMIT HIS
UNETHICAL ACTIONS SWUNG THE
ELECTION TO TRUMP AND BEG FOR
FORGIVENESS."
MY AUNT FANNY'S BEAN DIP MAKES
ME MILDLY NAUSEOUS.
CALL ME SWINGING THE ELECTION
TOOK TRUMP MAKES ME SICK.
>> EVERY TIME I SEE THEM, I BURP
A LITTLE BIT IN MY MOUTH.
SANCTIMONIOUS, SELFISH,
SELF-INVOLVED PERSON.
A WORD I'VE NOT USED WITH HIM
AND I DON'T BELIEVE HE'S A LIAR.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE HIM, AND YOU
DON'T LIKE THE BOOK, DON'T BUY
THE BOOK.
WE ARE WHERE WE ARE.
THIS IS ABOUT BOB MUELLER.
BOB MUELLER IS IN THE MIDDLE OF
DOING SOMETHING WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT HE'S DOING.
WE KNOW WHAT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IS DOING AND WE KNOW WHAT
THE PRESIDENT IS DOING.
THEY ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY
CAN TO STOP THIS MAN.
>> Laura: DEMOCRATS TRIED TO
GO AFTER KEN STARR IN THE
'90s.
>> I DON'T IT'S A GOOD EXAMPLE
BECAUSE KEN STARR STARTED IN '94
AND WENT ON BEYOND BILL CLINTON
BEING IN OFFICE.
I DON'T KNOW WHY, WHAT IS
EVERYONE AFRAID OF TO JUST LET
THIS MAN DO HIS JOB?
>> THERE IS ANOTHER ISSUE.
JAMES COMEY'S JUDGMENT, IT GETS
TO THE CORE OF WHETHER HE DID A
GOOD JOB AS HEAD OF THE FBI.
TAKE THE INVESTIGATION OF
HILLARY.
WHETHER YOU AGREE WITH WHAT HE
FOUND HER DIDN'T, JAMES COMEY
HAD NO ROLE OR RESPONSIBILITY TO
USURP THE DUTIES OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND DECIDE
NO REASONABLE PROSECUTOR WOULD
SETTLE THIS CASE.
THE PROPER THING TO DO WOULD
HAVE BEEN TO SILENTLY MAKE HIS
DEFIANCE KNOWN       KNOWN TO TE
DEFIANCE KNOWN       KNOWN TO TD
DEFIANCE KNOWN       KNOWN TO TP
DEFIANCE KNOWN       KNOWN TO TR
DEFIANCE KNOWN       KNOWN TO TM
DEFIANCE KNOWN       KNOWN TO TN
DEFIANCE KNOWN       KNOWN TO TT
OF JUSTICE.
COMEY COULDN'T DO THAT BECAUSE
HE COULDN'T RESIST THE CAMERA.
HE HAD TO GO OUT AND HOLD A NEWS
CONFERENCE WHERE HE CONCLUDED
BASICALLY THAT HILLARY BROKE THE
LAW AND THEN HE SAID BUT NO
REASONABLE PROSECUTOR WOULD
PROSECUTE HER.
>> Laura: HE ALLOWED PETER
STRZOK AND A COUPLE OTHERS TO
EDIT THE REMARKS.
TO MAKE THEM NOT COMPORT.
HOW DO YOU DO THAT?
CAN I READ AN EXCERPT?
>> WE ARE WHERE WE ARE.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> SO WHAT.
JUST DON'T BUY HIS BOOK.
>> Laura: LET ME READ.
HOLD THE THOUGHT.
I WANT TO READ THIS ONE THING.
THIS IS A FULL SCREEN, ANOTHER
EXCERPT.
>> JIM COMEY DID EVERYTHING
WRONG PRIOR TO ELECTION DAY.
AND THEY REALLY DON'T CARE
WHETHER HE SAID SORRY.
APOLOGY NOT ACCEPTED.
>> Laura: IS THIS COMEY
STANDARD JUSTICE, JUSTICE BY
POLLING?
>> HE IS ENJOYING BEING THE HERO
AND THE VICTIM IN THE SPOTLIGHT
AND THE AUTHOR AND THE GUEST.
WE HAVE TO ENDURE IT FOR
15 MINUTES.
BUT HE STARTED SOMETHING THAT
WAS BASED ON LEGITIMACY THAT'S
BEEN HANDED OVER TO BOB MUELLER.
>> Laura: BASED ON LEGITIMACY?
WE CAN DO AN HOUR ON THAT,
WHETHER IT WAS A LEGITIMATE
OPENING OF INVESTIGATION?
>> YOU HAVE FIVE PEOPLE.
>> Laura: WE COULD GO THROUGH
A FLOOR OF ANY BUILDING.
IF YOU WANT TO INDICT SOMEONE.
>> MUELLER WAS A PERSON OF HIGH
IDEALS, CLEAR SENSE OF PURPOSE.
>> Laura: WE ARE NOT GOING TO
DO THIS.
>> IT IS ARI FROM 2001.
>> I STILL BELIEVE THAT ABOUT
BOB MUELLER.
BOB MILLER IS NOT JAMES COMEY.
WHERE JAMES COMEY SHOWS IS THAT
PROSECUTORS WHO HAVE BAD
JUDGMENT WILL MAKE MISTAKES, NOT
EVERYBODY IS PERFECT AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OR THE FBI
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OR THE FB
FBI.
IT'S AN INTERESTING AND
IMPORTANT REMINDER FOR BOB
MUELLER AS HE GOES FORWARD.
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT JAMES COMEY,
AND YOU SAID IT, THE THINGS HE
DID BEFORE THE ELECTION WERE
WRONG AND IT GOES BACK TO THE
BUSH ADMINISTRATION WHEN HE
GRAND STANDARD ON ONE OF THE
INTELLIGENCE PROGRAMS WE HAD AND
CREATED THIS WHOLE DRAMA ABOUT
HIMSELF WHEN THERE WAS A PROGRAM
THE FBI HAD PREVIOUSLY APPROVED
THAT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
PREVIOUSLY APPROVED AND JAMES
COMEY HAD THIS DRAMATIC MOMENT
AT OUR HOSPITAL TO REVERSE
EVERYTHING THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE PREVIOUSLY DID.
>> Laura: I'VE GOT HER READ.
IT'S LIKE PILLOW TALK.
THIS IS COMEY ON LORETTA LYNCH,
WHETHER SHE WAS IMPARTIAL.
SO WE FIND OUT IN THIS BOOK THAT
THERE'S INFORMATION FOR MAKING
CALL INTO QUESTION THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S INDEPENDENCE
AND OVERSEEING THIS
INVESTIGATION.
>> WE ALREADY KNOW.
HE LEFT IT OUT BECAUSE HE'S
EMBARRASSED.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" REPORTED
MONTHS AGO THAT HE FELL FOR A
FAKE EMAIL SOMEONE IN THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN, SENT FROM A
WOMAN NAMED LORETTA LYNCH WAS AN
ENERGY LOBBYIST IN CALIFORNIA.
THE GUY IS NAIVE.
THE GUY IS A RUBE.
BOB MUELLER'S COMMAND WE SHOULD
BE TALKING ABOUT.
BOB MUELLER WAS APPOINTED.
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT COMEY
BECAUSE HE'S WRITING A BOOK.
>> HE IS WRITING A BOOK THAT LED
TO THE INVESTIGATION.
>> COMEY HAS BEEN DEIFIED BY THE
PRESS CORPS.
THEY LOVED HIM WHEN HE TOOK ON
BUSH.
THEY LOVED HIM WHEN HE LET
HILLARY GO.
>> Laura: HE LOVES BEING IN
THE SPOTLIGHT.
HE LOVES HIS MOMENT IN THE SUN.
>> I THAT YOU WANT US TO HER, NO
ONE IS GOING TO ASK HARD
QUESTIONS.
SUCH AS YOU SAID YOU LEAKED THAT
MEMO TO THE COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY
PROFESSOR.
WHO ELSE DID YOU ROUTINELY LEAK
THINGS TO?
>> Laura: WE ARE OUT OF TIME.
WE FORGOT TO MENTION THAT.
ANYONE WHO GETS IN THE CAR AND